liberals are destroying American
University's liberal colleges have
become experts at silencing conservative
speakers that's how campuses are now
free speech a very scary situation we're
on the campus at Arizona State
University
because as everyone knows college escape
we're undercover as students note the
minions backpacks finger on the pulse to
try and save College from its liberal
chokehold
thankfully some heroic student groups
are injecting conservative ideas back
into university life groups like Turning
Point USA an organization with over
three hundred chapters on college
campuses nationwide we attended one of
their events which meant we could change
back into fashionable adult clothes
thank god this young rebel is Charlie
Kirk founder of Turning Point USA a
group elevating the dialogue on campus
our turning point is Saint members they
just want to talk about capitalism free
markets the Constitution right like the
time they book Milo a innopolis two-out
trans students I have known some passing
trannies in my life it's just a man in a
dress isn't it or when they protested
safe spaces by wearing diapers pigs you
laugh and think but those aren't the
only ways they hilariously troll
sensitive liberals this group Turning
Point the USA set up the so-called
affirmative action bake till he needless
to say it caused quite a stir for those
people I don't know in front of action
bake sale is kind of a cheeky fun
activism event if you will you are
charged more if you are an Asian or a
white student and if you're a black
student you're charged less what's the
goal with it I think more than thing
else it's an educational tool and look I
think there's nothing wrong with racial
and ethnic diversity however next just
equally as important type of diversity
is intellectual and ideological
diversity we need someone to take action
in an affirmative way to get more
conservatives onto campus correct and
that's part of what Turning Point USA is
doing which is different than uplifting
underrepresented individuals
somehow I don't know ask me tomorrow
either way we wouldn't need conservative
affirmative action if liberal brainwash
professors weren't stifling our speech
if only we knew who they were
the professor watchlist is a project of
turning-point USA the mission is to
expose college professors who
discriminate against conservative
students and yes liberals we know that
McCarthy also made naughty lists but so
does Santa you can't hate Santa but most
you eat Christmas it's not professor
blacklist and it's not professor hit
list it's an awareness tool we're not
calling for the termination of these
professors let let the schools make
their own decisions there it's like the
crucible you might have to hang some
Protestants but if you catch a witch
it's worth it
okay no but okay no but is right and
some professors actually want to be on
the list
Amanda Kaley is a professor of
literature sorry literate Huck sorry
reading she recently asked turning-point
to be put on their watch list in what
she calls an act of solidarity with her
colleagues and what we call being
thirsty as hell I know personally who
have been on the list
we're both subjected to threats and
weeks of harassing recess and misogynist
emails you're not even on the list so
it's like nothing Bad's gonna happen to
you right
simply because I came out against
turning-point USA and got in their
crosshairs
I've had several elected officials here
in the state of Nebraska call for me to
be fired and the Nebraska Republican
Party even submitted an open records
request demanding to see my private
political emails that mentioned Donald
Trump u.s. congressman Jeff Fortenberry
and u.s. senator Ben Sasse I hope they
don't ask for my emails on Ben Sasse
because they are so anxious
sure gaily almost got fired and some
losers got death threats but that's not
the fault of the professor watchlist
it's the fault of the people who read
the list and then took action because of
what they read on the list and it's
definitely not the fault of Charlie Kirk
and his awesome grassroots movement
twenty-point USA is not a grassroots
movement it is a billionaire funded
astroturf movement isn't it good to have
somebody from the outside come into the
university and sort of stir the pot yeah
sort of drain the universities well I
think we're doing a pretty good job with
talking about ideas on campus without
non-experts who have nothing really but
money and sinister motivations coming in
to try to stir things up for us wait
we're not experts with nothing but money
and whatever that other thing was plus
we're backed by a billionaire funded
organization so we hit campus to expose
college students to ideas so
underrepresented literally no one was
saying what's the big deal with eating
human flesh of that person asked you to
do it what none of your professors will
say stuff like this gay phrenology does
the shape of your make you care we think
what's the big deal at boy cousins
because you won't make a weird incest
baby I don't know okay
finally got one
[Music]
okay don't want to engage in a dialogue
interesting if college kids didn't want
to hear our unpopular ideas we'd find
ways to make them like turning-point
does with a little help from Republican
mega donors Turning Point has been
secretly and ingeniously funding student
government campaigns now they can
influence school policies on campus
carry or even fossil fuel usage and it's
not just turning-point the country's top
conservative youth organizations have
three times as much money as their
liberal counterparts
so while liberals rest on their laurels
thinking that college is firmly in the
hands of big professor we'll be here
making college a conservative wet dream
and we've got the guy who knows college
better than anyone so Charlie where did
you go to college I did go to college
which my son might say is weird sort of
home-schooled on the university level
yeah exactly right
[Music]